Dynamic policies are policies who's forwarding behavior can
change. They are represented as a time series
of static policies. The current value of the
policy at any time is self dot policy. A
common programming idiom in Pyretic is to set
a default policy, and then register a call
back that updates that policy. In the assignment,
you will create a similar topology that you created
in the pox assignment, but we will now
use pyretic to implement a simple switch and firewall.
In pyretic every first packet with a new
source mac address, at the switch is read by
a query. The policy is updated with a
new predicate, everytime a new mapping between a MAC
address and an output port is learnt. In
the assignment you also create a dynamic firewall policy,
register a callback to check the rules
and sequentially compose your firewall policy with
a learning switch, thus provided as part
of the pyritic distribution. In summary, pyretic allows
operators to write complex network policies as
functions. It allows an operator to express predicates
on packets, including things such as and,
or, and not. It provides the capability to
specify and modify virtual packet headers as packet metadata and it
provides ways to compose complex network policies from simpler independent ones.